aujourd'hui j'ai juste un appel ce matin
mais hier 7 3 puis la journée d'avancé 3
aussi des numéros indésirables qui sonne
à répétition patrick laroche ne les
compte plus tellement il en soit il est
loin d'être le seul service canada
ibrahim problème avec moi ou d'assurance
sociale
veuillez puis sur un pur parrainage des
fraudeurs qui se font passer pour des
fonctionnaires ou encore des policiers
ce n'est qu'un des stratagèmes utilisés
depuis une semaine le centre antifraude
a reçu une quarantaine de plaintes
concernant des appels répétitif
internationaux ou nationaux
d'évaluations aussi qu'on en reçoit un
appel où il ya seulement que ça sonne
seulement une fois puis après ça les
gens perdent contact donc n'ont pas le
temps de répondre à l'appel et déjà
terminée si on a beaucoup de gens qui
nous ont appliqué est un epic nous poser
la question qu'est ce qu'on fait ce
qu'on fait expert en faute conseil
d'ignorer les appels de ne jamais appuyé
sur le 1 et surtout de ne pas faire
comme moi contre le bénin ont essayé de
ne pas rappeler les numéros inconnus
je m'appelle 2000 euros raccroche au
sein parce que vous pourriez avoir à
payer des frais interurbains
difficile de savoir ce qui explique
cette nouvelle vague d'appels mais ce ne
serait pas étranger au récent vol de
données
suite à tous les vols de données qu'on a
connu cet été la fraude c'est le crime
dollars chaque dollar investi dans
rapporte 1000 dhs donc s'il faut par
exemple un million d'appels y au moins 5
% des gens qui vont sur la preuve
ce qui nous préoccupe le plus certains
ces deux niveaux de sollicitations mais
sont aussi que sa voix difficile de
quand même empêcher les fraudeurs
d'essayer de communiquer avec les
personnes actuellement même si vous
bloquez les numéros comme l'a fait
patrick les appels semble tout de même
se poursuivre donc c'est tout les
sociétés numéro bloqué les deux 2,6 foot
ou 2,5 2,6 à la demande du crtc les
entreprises téléphonique travaille
justement à l'élaboration d'un système
de blocage universel des appels et liste
qui doit être en place d'ici décembre